[intro music]
Okay, I'm gonna think about it this time
before I actually say it.
Good morning, John, it's
Thursday, February 8th.
It is.
It's very hard to make a video blog in this house
because there's nowhere private at all,
and I have to talk very quietly
or else people will look at me funny.
They're looking at me funny.
[high-pitched grunt]
I'm kind of hiding in the corner
in the living room,
which is the room that I sleep in,
in a sofa bed,
which is right here.
To start out today's video I'm
gonna give you a tour
of the place where I am right now.
I am officially in Englewood, Florida.
It's a very, very nice day.
There's cars coming, which is really
unusual for this street.
[car noise]
They would've hit me at the exact same time.
That would've been painful.
Yeah, see, now there's not gonna
be any cars for another 2 or 3 hours.
And, you look around, you'll see
a normal Florida 50's-style
ranch house neighborhood.
Very nice place.
Lots of citrus,
lots of flowers and cacti,
lots of American flags.
This is a donkey with a cactus in it
that miraculously survived
Katherine throwing her calculus book at it.
According to the sundial, it is 11:00.
This is remarkably accurate.
This mom has non-traditional pink flamingos.
Behind me now
is an orange tree.
Then over there
are two more orange trees and,
I think, a tangerine tree.
And then I'm going underneath
some banana trees now,
and then there's the canal.
It's a very nice place.
Moving along.
Katherine's parents just took me to a very
interesting
event.
there were about 400 old people
watching about 30 old people
playing banjos.
Badly.
It turns out that Charlotte County has,
actually, the highest age of any county in the country.
There are a lot
of old people here
They played patriotic songs,
they played "Take me out to the ball game",
they played
more
patriotic songs,
and they played some military songs.
Anyways,
Whereas I've been thinking a
lot about babies lately,
you know, the beginning of life,
this made me think about something entirely different
I started to wonder,
were any of them going to die
while I was watching them?
So, I've done some B.O.N. calculations,
I love B.O.N. calculations,
"Back of Napkin".
Assuming that the average age
of people there was 70,
and assuming that there were
around 400 people there,
and using census data that says that
the average age of death
of a 70-year-old is 83,
I have calculated the probability
that someone would die
at the event that I just attended.
Because the average age of death
of a 70-year-old is 83,
half of the people
at the event
will be dead
in 13 years.
That is 113,000 hours.
Now, because I was at the event for 3 hours,
and there were 400 old people there,
that means
1,200 total old people hours.
You put that number over the total half-life
of an old person at the age of 70,
and then divide by 2,
and get a 0.53% chance that someone
would die within eye-shot of me
this afternoon.
While that's not a very big number,
it is probably the biggest that number has ever been
in my life.
So, now you know how bored I am.
I accept your challenge and will answer my survey
The 3 minute and 30 second time limit is going
to be quite a barrier but I will do my best.
and I very much enjoyed
your children's book
I'm considering doing the illustrations
for it myself.
I'll see you tomorrow.